tell me about the elevator fight in the
elevator
oh man tell us about that well
what happened was um and frank and i are
friends frank trigg
and i was on his podcast after that
happened and we both laid it out you can
look on the internet we can hear it out
of frank's voice my voice whatever but
what basically what happened is we had a
fight that night a
fight night of ufc fights and we were at
the hard rock hotel
okay so we're at the hard rock it's
after the fights and
i decided to go to mike goldberg's room
and there's frank trigg and we all had a
drink together
and we saw we're going to go out to
dinner i'm going to go out to a club
later have some fun
so we're on the 10th floor of the hard
rock hotel we walk to the elevator
and when the elevator opens there's dana
white and mike and
uh his security guy tom so we're walking
in
the doors have not even closed frank
immediately who
was saying to dana you know when are you
gonna put me in another fight and so
many words and
they were just exchanging a few things
and i'm a watch freak okay and dana had
this really cool watch on this watch
band
and so here's the elevator we walk in
i'm at the door frank is over here
dana's over here
and i turn to dana dana what a watch now
i'm sorry if i interrupted
the brief moment they were having you
know him asking for a job or whatever
the case might be because i don't mean
to do that
but when i did that i got a rich hand
he's over here i'm facing here and i get
a rich hand in my throat
i turn around frank you hit me why the f
did you hit me
and he said the wrong thing to me he
said well what are you going to do about
it
no no no no so i just i just reacted i
just went
boom you know and then it was on and now
the doors close
and and uh we're just throwing out each
other for ten floors i mean what is that
maybe we get back to the minute long
fight was that maybe
the elevator started moving the elevator
doors
closed as that happened now we're
starting to go down the ten floors
yeah some big guys and then boom boom
boom it was like small areas
so give me an elevator fight no i'm just
kidding so dana's up against the wall
like this and
security guys here and goldberg's here
and and all i was doing was going at it
with frank and it's like
we're going down and and then it just
bam bam bam and then he need me
and one of my friends and i felt that
and then
i shoulder turned him and pushed against
the elevator and he came back
and then i feel the doors opening behind
me right now if you remember the hard
rock hotel where you know the hard rock
hotel
on that bottom floor they have all the
memorabilia encased in glass
the way we were going at it we would
have spilled out of the elevator
and god forbid into the glass or
something and it would have been a scene
a scene that i don't want to be part of
right
so i just threw my arms in the air i
said we're done we're done we're done
and then it was over and you know the
adrenaline's flowing and
we're laughing and dangerous
automatically stopped too we stopped
yeah we stopped it
right and um dana's laughing we're
laughing adrenaline's flowing and then i
got blood up and down my shirt
my i look at my thumb and i can see the
bone in my thumb my
you know skin's peeled back it must have
hit his belt buckle or his watchers you
know how things happen
so i'm bleeding dana's smiling i'm
smiling frank's smiling
we're you know hugging each other like
bros like okay we had we had a 10
attempt
a friendly 10 attempt right it happens i
missed that when i was younger you have
a ted attempt you have a beer
okay so i had to go to the the
first aid station i said can you super
glue it they said no we can't gotta go
to the hospital right
so i go i go to the emergency room it's
empty i walk in i'm sitting in the room
waiting for the doctor to come in i'm
hearing my voice in the next room
announcing the fights because they're
watching the repeat
and the doctor walks in he's like this
the heck are you doing here
right so i got like seven stitches
tetanus shot 500
you know whatever went out had a good
time afterwards
hey you know what guys it was a fun
night i announced the ufc
i had a fun ted of ted an elevator in
front of my boss he knows he doesn't
have a wimp announcing his fighters
went out had some fun i felt like i was
28 years old i'll do it tomorrow night
let's do it
you